c'est dans un des hangars de l'aéroport
que se fait l'annonce car il n'y a pas
d'aérogare ici pas encore en tout cas
mais voici à quoi ressemblera ce que la
compagnie Powter Airlines s'engage à
construire 20 000 m² 9 portes
d'embarquement et le calendrier est
ambitieux l'aéroport Montréal
Saint-Hubert nous dit que les travaux
vont commencer dès le dégel ce printemps
pour faire sortir derrière moi cet
immense aérogare de 20.000 m² et qu'elle
soit livrées dans un peu plus de 18 mois
à l'automne 2024 le grand potentiel de
l'aéroport peut enfin se réaliser et la
nôtre aujourd'hui permettra à Longueuil
de consolider sa position de leader en
matière aérospatiale porteur desservira
une douzaine de villes au Canada au
départ de Saint-Hubert et s'associe aux
transporteurs régional Pascal pour une
dizaine de liaisons au Québec c'est
incontournable pour les entreprises pour
les ondes d'innovation qu'on est en
train de développer pour les étudiants
qui peuvent aller dans les différentes
régions pour les touristes pour cette
expert il ne fait presque aucun doute
que d'autres destinations vers les
États-Unis ou les Caraïbes viendront
s'ajouter une question de stratégie
d'aller ça par étape parce que tout d'un
coup quand on prend un trop gros boucher
peut-être qu'on pourra pas la vallée
tout de suite mais aussi l'acceptabilité
sociale peut-être qu'il y a des gens qui
sont méfiants par rapport à cette espèce
d'expansion tout d'un coup les
préoccupations sont grandes sur la
question des nuisances et certains
citoyens craignent une augmentation
rapide du nombre de Voltaire peut nous
dire maintenant que c'est deux vols mais
ça peut changer le mois prochain et
l'année prochaine donc on sait qu'il y a
une croissance
exponentielle avec ses compagnies
d'aviation qui sont très très friandes
de rendement mais la mairesse assure
avoir le soutien citoyen
[Rires]
au moment de l'ouverture de l'aérogare
on parle d'une vingtaine de vols
supplémentaires par jour mais ça
pourrait être quatre fois plus à terme
il y a des discussions actuellement avec
plusieurs transporteurs on espère faire
des annonces au cours des prochains mois
quant à l'accès à cette nouvelle
aérogare et à l'hôtel de 130 chambres
construit à côté porteur mettra en place
une navette électrique gratuite depuis
le métro Longueuil ici Mathieu pros
Radio-Canada Longueuil